I've been sent is pretty
interesting algebra problem,
and I think the question isn't
properly formed, or it might be
missing some piece
of information.
But it's an interesting
question nonetheless so I
thought I'd work it out,
and we can talk about why
it's not properly formed.
So they give us a
function, f of x.
They say it's a third degree
polynomial of the form
ax to the third plus bx
squared plus cx plus d.
And they tell us a couple of
the 0's of this polynomial.
They say that we have 0's at
the point minus 1, 0 and
the point 2 comma 0.
And they tell us we have a
y-intercept, y-intercept,
at the point 0, minus 2.
And what they ask us is, what
is a plus b plus c plus d?
So let's see if we can make
some headway on this.
So the first thing is to think
about, is what would a third
degree polynomial look like and
what are we even talking
about when we say 0's.
So let me just draw a
little bit of a graph.
And I don't know exactly what
this third degree polynomial
looks like just yet.
Let me draw my axis.
Now a third degree polynomial
can have as many as three 0's.
And 0's are just the
points where the
function is equal to 0.
So, we have a 0 at minus 1, 0.
So that's minus 1, 0,
that's right there.
We have a zero 2, 0.
1, 2, 0.
So those are the two 0's
that they've given us.
They also told us the
y-intercept at 0, minus 2.
So it intersects the
y-axis right there.
But this guy can have
as many as three 0's.
Now some of them
might be complex.
But complex 0's come in
pairs of two, the two
complex conjugates.
I won't go into too
much detail here.
So this one must have a third
real 0, because if the third
one was complex, you'd need
another complex 0, and you
can't have four 0's for a
third degree polynomial.
So that third root, it could
be sitting some place out
here, maybe over here.
Or it could even be a
repeat of one of these
two roots over here.
But let's just assume that
there's some third root, we
don't know what it looks like.
Let's say it looks something
like-- let's say that third
root is sitting out
here some place.
And then a potential graph, and
I could be completely wrong,
I'm just guessing, but just to
get a sense of what third
degree polynomials look like,
and how can a graph intersect
the x-axis three times, a
potential graph might look
something like this.
Curves and bam, hits the other
0, hits the y-intercept, and
then goes back up like that.
It might go like that, it might
go the other way, go like that.
Up, and then down like that.
Well, there's many ways you
could draw something that
essentially curves twice to
intersect these three points
and also that y-intercept,
but I'm not going to go into
all of those right now.
But let's see if we can figure
out the coefficients here.
So the key point is me
telling you that there
must be a third 0 here.
Let's call that third 0, it's
at the point, it's at the
point-- let's call
it --r3 comma 0.
And I'm using the
letter r for roots.
Roots are the x
values of the 0's.
So if we say f of minus 1 is
equal to 0, we say that x is
equal to minus 1 is a root.
Similarly, we know that f of
2, f of 2, is equal to 0.
Or we could say x equals 2
is a root, these are roots.
So when someone tells you a 0
they're also essentially
telling you the roots, and then
we know there must be a third
root at x is equal to r3.
So x is equal to r3.
Now, if we have a third degree
polynomial where these three x
values make it 0, we can
rewrite this third degree
polynomial as-- we can rewrite
it as-- I'll do it in a
slightly different color --f of
x is equal to x plus 1-- you'll
see why I'm doing x plus 1
instead of x minus 1 in a
second --plus 1 times x
minus 2 times x minus r3.
And we want to put an a out
front, and I'll tell you in
a second why I'm putting
this a out front.
Because if you were to multiply
just the x terms here, when
actually do your distributed
property and multiply out these
binomials, you'll just get x to
the third, but we had
an ax to the third.
So you just needed a constant
a there to make this
an ax to the third.
Now, why did I write
out like this?
Well, if you put a minus 1 in
here what's going to happen?
This term is going to
be minus 1 plus 1.
It's going to be 0.
Who cares what these are
or what a is, the whole
thing's going to be 0.
If we put x is equal
to 2, this term right
here is going to be 0.
Who cares what the other
terms or the a is, f
of 2 is going to be 0.
Similarly, when x is equal to
r3, this last term is 0, who
cares about anything over here.
So we know that this guy
up here can be rewritten
in this form over here.
And so if we can solve for r3
we can just multiply this thing
out and try to do a little bit
of pattern matching to figure
out what these coefficients
are going to be.
Now, the other big clue they
gave us is a y-intercept.
That point right there,
the point 0, minus 2.
They're telling us that f
of 0 is equal to minus 2.
Well what's f of 0?
f of 0-- I'll write it here --f
of 0-- If you put 0 in here,
this term becomes 0, this term
becomes 0, that term becomes 0,
you are just left with the d.
So f of 0 is equal to d.
Or we could say that d
must be equal to minus 2.
d is equal to minus 2, so
we solved at least one
of the call efficient.
The constant term. d
is equal to minus 2.
Now, if d is equal to minus 2,
that means all of these
constant terms, when you were
to multiply out this
expression, and I would include
the a, because the a is scaling
everything, that must
be equal to minus 2.
Let me be clear here.
So let me rewrite
this expression.
This is equal to, I'll just
multiply this a times
this last term.
We do it in any order you want,
so this is the same thing as x
plus 1 times x minus 2 to times
a a minus r, let me
write, minus ar3.
This is the exact same thing as
this thing up here, I'll just
write this is with f of x is
equal to, and this is the exact
same thing is that up there.
Now, to solve for an r3, or
attempt to solve for an r3, you
just have to realize that when
you multiply this thing out,
the way to get the constant
term over here, or the d over
here, that's going to be a
product of the constant
terms in our expressions.
Because if I introduced any
products with any x terms,
you're going to get one of
these other terms over here.
The ax cubed term is generated
from that term, that term,
and that term, being
multiplied together.
and then the constant term
is multiplied by the
constant terms to be
multiplied together.
And then the two in the middle
are multiplied by different
combinations of constant terms.
And you'll see that if
you actually want to
multiply this out.
But if you take my word for it,
that times that times that
times, actually let me
write it this way.
That times that times that,
have got to be equal to date we
can then attempt to find some
relationship between a and d,
which is mine is minus 2.
So we could say 1 times minus
2 times minus ar3, these two
minuses will cancel out.
It is going to be
equal to our d terms.
It's going to be equal to minus
2, and so if we simplify that a
little bit we get 2ar3 is equal
to minus 2, divide both sides
by 2a and you get r3 is
equal to minus 1/a.
So we haven't solved for the
third root, we've just gotten
it in terms of, in terms
of our coefficient a.
But letls see if we can still
use that in some useful way.
So if r3 is minus 1/a, this
term right here becomes what?
Let me rewrite it.
All right, I'll do it in blue.
f of x is going to be equal to
x plus 1 times x minus 2 times
ax-- now minus a times r3.
Let me do it over here.
Minus a times r3
three is minus 1/a.
So that's a minus
times a minus.
That's a plus.
The a's cancel out.
You just get a 1.
So this term now if we
substitute r3 with this will
just turn into a this will
just turn into a plus 1.
Minus a times minus
1/a that's plus 1.
Plus 1.
We just substituted that for
that to get this right here.
Now let's multiply
this thing out.
Let's actually do the
algebraic multiplication
and see what we get.
So first I'm going to
multiply these two terms.
I'm going to do it in
a different color.
Let me multiply those
two terms right there.
So this is going to be equal to
x squared, x squared plus 1x
minus 2x So that's
minus x, right?
1 times x is x, minus 2
times x is x minus 2x.
So it's minus x, and then minus
2, just multiplied these two
binomials out right here.
And then I'm going to have to
multiply that times ax plus 1,
so I'm going to write the
ax plus 1 down here
just to save space.
ax plus 1.
And now we just do a little bit
of algebraic multiplication.
1 times minus 2 is-- I'll do
it in magenta --minus 2.
1 times minus x is minus x.
1 times x squared is x squared.
Now ax times minus
2 is minus 2ax.
Minus 2ax.
ax times minus x is minus
ax squared, right?
Minus ax squared and
then ax times x squared
is ax to the third.
ax to the third.
Then we add everything
together, and we get our f of x
is going to be equal to ax to
the third-- let me scroll to
the left a little bit
--ax to the third.
x squared minus ax squared.
So that's plus 1 minus
a, 1 minus a x squared.
And then we have these two
added together so this is minus
1 minus 2a or we could call
this equal to-- so minus 1
minus 2a --or we could say
minus 1 plus 2ax and then we
have our minus 2, which makes
sense because that is our d.
That's our d.
So this is really the solution.
This is the form that are
equation is going to take and
the reason why I said in the
beginning of the problem that
the equation or the problem
wasn't well defined is that I
can pick any real number a
and this equation will
satisfy these conditions
that we were given.
So I suspect that I wasn't
given all of the constraints
on this problem.
Maybe there was a third
constraint that a is equal to
1, or b is equal to something
else, or a plus b is
equal to something else.
But just using these
constraints, just using these
constraints, the equation
will take this form.
So, if it was in this form, of
course this is a, this is b,
which would be 1 minus a,
that's b, that's a, and then
this right here is equal to c.
So we could pick, you know, we
could pick one particular
choice if we just want to get
an answer to their problem, but
it might not be the answer they
were looking for because they
might have picked
a different a.
But if you just pick a simple
a is equal to 1, than
what's b equal to?
Then b is equal to 1 minus
a, which is equal to 0.
Then b is equal to 0, and then
c is equal-- actually c would
include this minus sign right
there --c would be one plus 2a.
So 2a is 2, 1 plus 2 is 3.
Put a minus sign.
So c would be equal to minus 3.
And of course no matter
what we do, d is going
to be equal to minus 2.
So if we pick a is equal to 1,
the answer here to what is a
plus b plus c plus d, would
be equal to 1 plus minus 3.
1 plus minus 3 is minus 2.
Minus another minus
2 is minus 4.
That's another possibility, but
we just as easily could have
picked, you know a could have
been something, it could be a
fraction, it could be anything.
It could be, you know
a could be minus 1.
a could be equal to minus 1, if
a is equal to minus 1, then b
is equal to 2, then b
is equal to 2, right?
1 minus minus 1.
And then c is equal to 1 minus
2, which is minus 1, but then
you have a minus out front.
So then c is equal to 1,
and then d is always going
to be equal to minus 2.
d is equal to minus 2.
And then you have a plus b plus
c plus d would be equal to.,
well these would cancel out,
you'd get them equal to 0.
So, we don't know exactly what
answer the problem writer
was looking for, but it is a
pretty interesting problem.
And then you know, just out of
curiosity, it-- let's take this
first example that we took
--where a is equal to 1, we
could then look at what
our root must be.
If a is equal to 1, then our
third root is that r3 would be
equal-- that's just for this
situation right here --than r3
would be equal to negative 1
divided by 1 would be equal to
minus 1, which means that we
would have a repeated root, we
would have a repeated
root, right there.
We wouldn't necessarily have
a distinct root out there.
And if we're curious about what
that would look like, let's
look at the situation
where a is equal to 1.
Actually maybe we wil
look at both of them.
When a is equal to 1, our
equation is x to the third--
where is the x button --x to
the third, there's no x
squared term, minus 3x minus
3x, minus 3x, minus 2.
So let's grab both of
them simultaneously.
So that's this one, where
we picked this choice
of coefficients.
And then let's do this choice
of coefficients, if we have, if
we have minus x to the third,
right? a is minus 1 plus 2 x
squared, and then we have, plus
x, c is 1, plus x minus 2.
So those are 2 graps.
Let's see what they look like.
Let's graph them.
So our first one, there we
go, we hit that point,
that's our double root.
Notice, both of these
two graphs meet our
two constraints.
They both have a root
there at minus 1.
They both have a y-intercept
at y is equal to minus 2.
And they both have a
root at x is equal to
positive 2 right there.
Now the second one right here
had a separate distinct third
root, while the first one,
here, has a double root
right over there.
Anyway, I actually think this
problem was somewhat more
interesting by the fact we
had to actually look at the
different solutions to it.
And there's actually an
infinite number of solutions
to this based on what
you choose for your a.